[Music]
have you ever met someone who always
feels cold even when everyone else is
warm we tend a joke that these people
are cold blooded but do we even know
what that means having cold blood
involves more than just needing a few
more blankets than everyone else if we
all suddenly became cold blooded instead
of warm our lives would be completely
different why would we need to eat less
food could we only survive in warm
climates and how might our cold blood
help with space exploration this is what
if and here's what would happen if
humans became cold-blooded when our body
temperatures get too hot or too cold
we have built-in processes like
shivering and sweating to help regulate
them but cold-blooded or ectothermic
creatures don't have that same luxury
that means that if we became cold
blooded our lives would be a lot more
limited and in the winter a good heater
could be the difference between life or
death do you think we'd be able to
survive if you were to wake up tomorrow
with cold blood
there'll be a lot of new things to get
used to some good and some bad
for one thing your grocery bill would be
a lot smaller as you wouldn't have to
eat nearly as much as you do now
warm-blooded animals eat a lot because
they need all that energy to keep their
bodies at the right temperature but what
if you like your three meals a day sure
you could keep eating as much as you
like but with no use for all those
calories all that food would go straight
to fat if you're smart about it you
probably wouldn't have to worry about
visiting the doctor as much anymore
either
our warm-blooded bodies provide a nice
constant temperature for germs to
breathe in as opposed to the variable
temperatures of the cold blooded
if bacteria and viruses can't get used
to your body's climate then your chances
of getting sick dropped significantly
but that's not to say that you'd be
invincible if you don't make a conscious
effort to keep yourself warm your low
body temperature could slow down your
immune system allowing bacteria and
viruses to creep up and infect you so
you may have become a less desirable
host for these pathogens but now you
also have an active responsibility in
fighting them off keeping yourself at a
proper body temperature would become a
crucial part of your everyday life since
you'd be relying on external sources of
heat your house would have to be kept
much warmer than you're used to your
thermostat would not only control the
temperature of your house it would be
setting the exact temperature you want
your body to be to during the winter any
money you would have saved on groceries
would be quickly gobbled up by a
sky-high heating bill cold-blooded land
dwellers tend to do best in temperatures
between 21 to 40 degrees Celsius so to
make things easier for ourselves and to
live more active lives we'd all be best
to move closer to the equator except
that would be a lot of people to move to
one area of the planet and soon we'd be
running into the usual issues that come
along with large-scale human migration
did it be overcrowded our resources
would be running out and who knows how
long it would take before political
instability came into play so maybe it
would be better if some of us just move
to another planet altogether yeah it's a
little ambitious but bear with me
because space travel should actually be
much easier for cold-blooded humans when
cold-blooded animals hibernate over the
winter they lower their body
temperatures to that other surroundings
and enter a state called torpor in this
catatonic state their breathing and
heart beats slow down and they can
survive for long periods on stored body
fat by employing this method a cold
blooded space crew could survive much
longer than a warm-blooded one allowing
them to travel for months or even years
on minimal resources may be out there in
space they'd find a planet that's
perfectly suited for cold-blooded
creatures and maybe there are already
some living there but that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]
you